sometimes people make sense video
requests for movies we've already done
sometimes we get asked to make t-shirts
that already exist in our store so we
got to thinking as this channel has
grown maybe there are some things some
of you don't know about and maybe we can
help inform you
ie shamelessly promote a few things
Twitter hey do you know about Twitter
well we're on it it's all the rage I'm
told and sometimes Jeremy tweets stupid
commentary on movie news and pictures of
his cats it's awesome you can follow us
at cinemasins t-shirts we'd want to be
whoring sellouts but we also recognize
some fans want shirts so we do have a
store and we do have lap dance shirts
and roll credits shirts and Prometheus
school of running away from think shirts
and it's at district lines calm /
cinemasins we try not to pimp it out too
much Jeremy's channel our narrator
Jeremy pink has his own channel where he
does stupid audio mashups dickish
letters to Hollywood movie lists and
more there's no regular posting schedule
no rhyme or reason to the order of
videos and it's sort of experimental oh
and no bleeping of any swear words so if
that sounds like your bag check it out
other channels we also have Branson's
and music video Sims 2 channels that
take the sin concept to other targets
brands and music videos tumblr do you
tumble we do two gifts jokes videos and
more reblog it cinema - since tumblr
comm reddit there is an official
cinemasins subreddit on reddit i am
actually one of the mods i also have no
idea what that means
talk cinemasins with other redditors at
reddit.com slash are slash cinemasins
Facebook yes we finally have a facebook
enough of you asked about it that we
finally broke down sound like tumblr
we'll be posting things there from
videos to thoughts on ville news and
more it's at facebook.com slash gww
cinema since that's e-w cinemasins i
pronounce the word w correctly w
want to see what growing YouTube
channels do when they're still young and
experimenting a lot look no further than
our own history at our admittedly
ridiculous song and music video gay for
Gandalf or Jeremy's misguided acapella
song about the movie gravity
or our recreation of famous movie
moments using Grand Theft Auto 5